joining us now is the conservative party
co-chair Amanda Milling hello to you
thanks for joining us this morning you
were favorites to win why didn't you so
it's a really disappointing result but
first of all I want to pay tribute to
Ryan Stevenson who's been an absolutely
fantastic candidate he's worked his
heart out day in day out and also to
congratulate Kim but this was always
going to be a really tough battle for us
we didn't win this in 2019 governing
parties don't tend to win by-elections
and we have to be clear on this this is
a labor hold not a labor game favorites
to win you I mean the polls were
suggesting that you would get 47 of the
vote you got 34 why do you think that is
I suppose one thing I would always say
about elections is only one poll that
matters and that's the one on the day
you know we've fought a really hard
campaign but what I would say it was a
very very close result you know as and
as I say
um governing parties don't win
by-elections they certainly don't gain
by election they certainly lost two on
the bands haven't you so each of these
by-elections is a unique challenge it
was really disappointing to lose chesh
and ramacham but you know we had we
fought a really um hard fight but let's
be really clear about this this is not a
great win for the labor party you know
this was we really kind of took the
fight to them they only won by a matter
of just over 300 as I said the polls
were suggesting that you're going to win
easily
um it's the Hancock effect isn't it so
there's a whole load of issues that
affected you know our campaign it's lots
of issues that come up on the doorstep
you know we fought a really hard
campaign I'm really disappointed and
particularly disappointed for Ryan
um but you know at the end of the day
you know this wasn't a great result for
labor you have to concede that the
behavior of your former Health secretary
must have had some impact on people in
Batley and spend who were honest
hard-working people and don't like the
way he behaved so you know it was
something that came up on the doorstep I
have to be honest about that but then
lots and lots of different what did they
say they had some issues until over the
weekend in terms of
um you know what happened but Matt
resigned that was the right thing to do
but there's a whole host of different
issues that came up but we also need to
remember that governing parties don't
gain by-elections and actually taking it
to such a small number of votes in
itself was a tremendous result quite
extraordinary I would say so the people
in Batley and spend at the weekend were
saying uh we don't like the way that uh
that he behaved and I'm guessing they
also didn't work particularly pleased
with the way that the Prime Minister
said the case is closed in a very
Superior manner so you know Mark did the
right thing at the weekend which was to
resign and within 24 hours the story
breaking we had a new health secretary
and sergeyev is doing a tremendous job
he's literally kind of work out from day
one because at the end of the day we're
still in the middle of this pandemic
we've got a job to do to ensure that we
roll out these vaccines so that we can
then open up the country and get back to
life as normal any answer to my question
what were people saying about the prime
minister at the weekend so they you know
there's a lot of love for the Prime
Minister you know he gets a tremendous
loss of support on the doorstep and you
know as I say you know Matt did the
right thing to resign and within 24
hours we had new health secretary yeah
love on the doorstep didn't translate to
a win though did it um let's talk about
Matt Hancock
um what has what's happened as far as
the investigation is concerned into his
behavior so the amount of Investigation
is something that I'm you know I'm not
here to discuss this morning the thing
is we had a by-election we've just had a
result in yeah we've dealt with that
we've dealt with that why is there no
investigation into Matt Hancock you're
the co-party chair so I don't talk about
investigations why do you understand
because individual cases are such as
and I'm not like I say I'm not going to
get drawn investigation be gone into
what happened so as I say I'm not going
to get drawn into any kind of
discussions in terms of Investigation
it's all I would say I don't understand
why not we should know what's happening
as far as the former Health secretary is
concerned he was Snogging his Aid in his
office when he was supposed to be
dealing with a pandemic tried to hang on
prime minister said the matter was
closed the British public said hang on a
minute as a result he stepped down we
should know what's happening as far as
the investigation is concerned so surely
it has to be transparent surely it does
so in terms of all I would say is this
morning I'm here with on the back of a
by-election result you know we have
literally
and you acknowledge right and you
acknowledge as part of that by-election
it was the behavior of the former Health
secretary that cost you that result of
different issues so I'm asking you as a
follow-up question what happened in
relation to the investigation so there
was a lot of different issues that came
up on the doorstep and yeah actually
let's look at this result it was an
incredibly good you know we were really
so close and governing parties shouldn't
be within a whisker of gaining um
by-election yeah you were close but as
you said there's only one result that
matters and you lost
um as far as him employing his mistress
at taxpayers expense what's happening as
far as that's concerned so there are you
know some of these matters are matters
for uh the government and you know no no
no no they're matters for the public
they want to know about uh the former
Health secretary paying his mistress 15
000 pounds of taxpayers
what are you doing about it so there are
processes that we go through in terms of
in terms of appointments and that all
the processes work gone through in
accordance to to those and so you know
so I think that kind of answers your
question well it doesn't I have a
follow-up if I may did you know that he
was paying his mistress fifteen thousand
pounds so like I say um there was a
story that broke last week I didn't know
any of the details of that but there are
due process in terms of these
appointments and those processes we've
gone through and does that due process
allow for a minister to pay 15 000
pounds to his mistress so this this is a
story which you know Matt has rightly
resigned he um recognized that he he did
wrong and that the you know we now need
to move on we in the middle of a
pandemic Sajid Javid has taken on as a
health secretary he's doing a tremendous
job because what we need to do right now
when they stood in the middle of this
pandemic we need to get these vaccines
rolled out in order to be able to get
the country back to normal yeah however
we don't move on until we find out why
he was paying his mistress 15 000 pounds
to snog in his office but he was that
was an appoint that was made through due
process well how can it be through due
process when he was paying his mistress
that whatever process you look at by
whatever measure that is not acceptable
to the British public to the extent
where you've lost a by-election so I
know the public will be incredibly
frustrated because at the end of the day
we have all made a huge number of
sacrifices
um you know we are we want to get back
to normal but Matt did the right thing
by resigning so is the matter closed now
is that what you're saying he's now
resigned so I would see that as kind of
the matter is closed so there is no
investigation
as I say you know Matt has done the
right thing in terms of resigning and
you know I understand the public
Australia have been deeply frustrated by
um kind of all of the issues that we've
faced over the last 12 months the
sacrifices they've made but you know I
wanted to all pull together as we kind
of get those vaccines rolled out so that
we can get the country back up and
running will there be an investigation
or not
as I say you know I think the matter is
closed now Matt has so there won't be an
investigation into our health secretary
during the middle of a global pandemic
where we've lost 120 000 people uh just
in the United Kingdom he's spent some of
his time paying his mistress 15 000
pounds a year taking her on G7 trips up
to Birmingham and Snogging her in his
office no matter is closed as far as
that's concerned no investigation has
you know that he broke the law
so the the you know Matt resigned at the
weekend he is no longer the health
secretary and you know now our Focus has
got to be on getting those vaccines
rolled out and getting the country back
to normal he broke the law
I I think that you know people have made
mistakes in the UK in terms of um the
the rules during the course of the last
12 months as you know yourself and so
you know I think Matt has he resigned
the law Matt has resigned and you know I
so there should be no comeback as far as
uh the health secretary is concerned and
he should be welcome back to uh
government within the course of a year
which is apparently what he's planning
to do well it doesn't matter for kind of
who is appointed to ministerial
positions as a matter for the Prime
Minister you know right now marked the
right thing by resigning and the fact
that he broke the law that that's the
matter clothes as I say people have
broken the rules okay as you well know
and so yeah
as you know you've made the point twice
as you know I was sanctioned I was off
there for six months uh I don't make
policy you do and he certainly did at
the time
does he have to face any comeback as a
result of breaking the law during a
global pandemic and Snogging with
he did the wrong thing he recognizes
that and he resigned and that was the
right thing for him to do okay is there
going to be an investigation as I say
the ma you know Matt has resigned is
there going to be an investigation Matt
has resigned and you know we've now got
a new health secretary and you know we
have got to focus now on uh whether or
you know getting this country back up
and running getting these vaccines
rolled out okay so when he was supposed
to be making policy uh and when he was
rolling out these uh inoculations and
went 120 000 people died and when he was
telling people they couldn't hug their
grandmother before they died
um all of that while he was also having
a relationship with his aide in his
office and also paying that a 15 000
pounds of taxpayers money that doesn't
warrant an investigation so look I can
understand why the public would be
deeply frustrated we have all made so
many sacrifices people up and down the
country who have been able to be with
their loved ones and and that Matt has
resigned he recognized he did wrong and
you know the public um
understandably are frustration yeah they
are that's why you've lost a violation
the reason you're sitting here this week
this morning are saying it doesn't
matter so we didn't lose a by-election
she said it was brought up on the
doorsteps what happened is the labor
held the seat they held the seat only by
a whisker you were you were this is not
a great success for the labor party and
why is for you and why it's not a loss
risk if you had we didn't gain the seat
it wasn't ours to lose it was the labor
parties to lose okay it's good to talk
to you I'm sorry we're gonna have to
leave it there look forward to you
coming back very soon indeed thank you